made you become a chemist a professional
chemist what actually made you end up
doing it as your job well I think from
quite a young age as a child I had
assumed I would become a scientist my
father was a physicist my grandfather
was a physicist so it was assumed I
would become a scientist and so it was
really a choice of which subject I
should do I quite enjoyed biology and I
did all sorts of biological experiments
when I was oh I suppose more zoology
I prepared skeletons of animals I still
have a skeleton of a rabbit at home I
bought the rabbit to the butch I didn't
kill it myself
and so but in the end I found chemistry
more interesting I thought I was pretty
good at it and I did he I went to
university to do chemistry and at the
end of that time I felt like I wasn't
finished studying
I wanted to know some more chemistry so
I ended up doing a PhD and then I ended
up doing research in the US and that
brought me here
there nothing him I chose my a-levels
towards a career in accountancy and I
sort of had a part-time job doing
accountancy and it bored me rigid so I
gave up all of my UK haka applications
to university and I decided to realign
myself and and to do the subject which I
really really enjoyed which was
chemistry well I chose to do a degree in
chemistry mainly because I found it the
easiest subject that I've done at any
levels you do your a-levels so in high
school you do your your your chemistry
courses night so I'd take chemistry
further just because I found it
interesting and I found that I was
relatively good at it which helps I
suppose I was a pretty terrible student
I have to say in the first couple years
I was enjoying the full student life not
always getting my coursework done on
time
but then I did a year in industry in
what was at the time SmithKline Beecham
pharmaceuticals and I was lucky enough
to work with a fantastic bunch of people
there we were working on a natural
product which is where my interest for
that area came along it's actually a
heartworm based compound for collie dogs
but it really infused me I loved working
in the lab I love making stuff we were
making stuff which is gonna matter it's
gonna help people help dogs in this case
and it fired me up I read loads I did
allowed to work and I'll also taught me
that you know my boss I'm probably not
an easy person to have an under a
manager and then I thought well what do
I want to do for my degree so chemistry
was the the the choice you know then and
when I started my research project is a
finally undergraduate I kind of started
to realize how much I enjoyed the
research which is probably why why why
most of us get into academia is because
we really enjoy the academic research
and I decided at that point that I
really didn't want to work for a big
corporation
I loved the lab work but I didn't like
the whole corporate business I wanted to
be an academic because there you get to
do exactly your own ideas go and have
your own personal vision of what
research will be doing in that that for
me was gonna be the career I I'd love to
say there was a grand master plan but
there wasn't it was a case of I
originally wanted to be a pharmacist and
bluntly speaking I just wasn't clever
enough to do that I just there were a
number circumstances that meant that I
couldn't do it it's just a fascinating
subject you get to understand what's
going on at the atomic level you get to
move atoms around and get them to
exchange partners and different bonding
environments it's just really
fascinating aspect of chemistry and it
underpins everything in modern day
Society when I worked industry I worked
in an industry involved in chemistry
I saw the value I saw the application of
chemistry firsthand which I probably
didn't see in school then I kind of just
realized how important chemistry was so
the society and the economy and then I
was like it just got more interested and
looked into it more and more and realize
wow it's involved in everything around
us so were kind of Kotler the chemistry
bug I guess but I still enjoyed doing
Sciences and therefore I kind of I knew
there's certain things I didn't want to
do with my degree and I came out and I
thought what am i what am i good what am
i enjoyed and during my PhD I'd worked
with a guy called Graham Jones doing
public engagement of science I love
talking to people I loved being able to
communicate science in the way that was
accessible but without being patronizing
or too much dumbing down and it was just
being able to see people say actually
yeah science is a really good thing I
get it now I understand what you're
talking about and that gave me quite a
buzz and I thought this is a kind of
career like but at that time you know in
the early 2000s it was just an there was
no job market for that sort of thing and
so when this job came up at Nottingham
public awareness scientist unique to the
UK I thought give it a go and so now
this is what I do